welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in black panther 2 is happening
premiering at may 6 2012 I'm cooler and
Marvel head Kevin Feige revealing the
news at d23 and while details about the
plot are still under wraps unresolved
Easter eggs and recent MCU films a ton
of online speculation and recent shake
ups in the future Marvel lineup of
projects all point to one character
potentially joining T'Challa in the
kingdom of Wakanda in this sequel Namor
the Submariner I'm gonna break down
everything we know about black panther 2
and why Namor could be the best choice
for a new MCU character to introduce in
it and spoiler warning the case any of
this ends up being right ruins your life
okay coming to May 20-22 black panther 2
is the first Marvel release beyond the
phase 4 lineup announced at Comic Con in
July we can assume that chadwick boseman
will return and a Koi a actress Danai
gurira confirmed she would be in it as
well remember the last we saw Wakanda
they were celebrating in victory after
the defeat of Thanos forces and vendors
in-game and now the nation exists
publicly on the world stage since
T'Challa came out at the UN at the end
of black panther with his people now
taking responsibility with outreach
efforts to underprivileged communities
but early on an endgame many notice this
interesting exchange between Natasha and
equation reading on those tremors it was
a mild subduction under the African
plate do we have a visual how are we
handling it net it's an earthquake under
the ocean we handle it by not handling
it hmm when asked whether this was
intended to be a reference to Namor
co-director Joe Russo said with a smile
maybe and the end game screenwriters in
a name they deny this intention but
these days I don't really trust any of
these four goobers - honestly report
what is and is not going on in their own
damn movie but it is clear that the MCU
is intending to set up named ORS
existence in this universe our first
reference double Conda showed up all the
way back in Iron Man 2 on a shield map
in the background with a marker over the
location of Wakanda but also on the map
is another marker smack in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean so let us take this
opportunity to remind everyone of who
Namor is exactly and whether he will
show this much skin in the MCU I mean we
probably will it's it's the MCU
so Namor the Submariner is one of the
oldest superheroes from Marvel Comics
he's kind of known as Marvel's Aquaman
but that's not really accurate because
they actually predate Aquaman
he showed up in the world war 2 era
comics alongside Captain America
fighting Nazis his mother Fenn was a
princess from a previously unknown
Atlantean Empire under the sea near
Antarctica his father Leonard McKenzie
was on a vibranium expedition then spied
on these humans end up falling in love
with McKenzie later giving birth to his
child named Warren so after name Ward's
Golden Age years he showed up again
later for the Fantastic Four he kind of
developed as a reputation as a womanizer
kind of a dick he often played an
antihero role attacking land dwellers
now Namor has all these standards
superhuman abilities speed strength
combat agility to communicate with sea
life even the ability to fly little
wings on his feet and he's also
considered Marvel's first mutant now not
the oldest mutant in Marvel's historical
timeline that'd be like apocalypse the
Namor was the first mutant to appear in
comic publication recent black panther
comics have actually established a
relationship between Namor and T'Challa
they're both rulers of hidden kingdoms
with adverse relationships with the
outside world but Namor showed judgement
to T'Challa for opening his arms to
other land dwellers so that brings us
back to that moment with a coy aide
in-game underwater disturbances that she
doesn't want Black Widow and the others
looking into hmm perhaps equaiiy is
trying to cover up a skirmish between
the nation of Wakanda in another secret
kingdom perhaps Atlantis and named or
criticized Wakanda for its role in the
lost at Thanos it was on wakandan soil
where thanasis acquired that final
infinity stone and used it to kill half
of all living creatures including a
number of named wars loved ones Namor
could argue that had to chala not
revealed wakanda's existence is a public
sanctuary things could have gone down
differently or going back further had
what conduct kept a better track of its
vibranium Ulysses Klaw couldn't have
stolen it giving it to Ultron where it
would then have been used to eventually
create the Android body that became
vision making the mine stones quick
destruction that much more difficult
years later I'm not saying I agree with
all these arguments but you know I
assume fish people don't always think
logically now Namor even appearing in
the film has always been a bit
complicated on the business side because
in the past Universal Studios has owned
the distribution rights to the character
like they do for the Hulk which by the
way is why it's hard for Hulk to
headline and as an own MCU movie now
that Disney owns Marvel but some things
have changed first Universal once
pursued making a name or movie with
legendary
that fell through in name or status as a
mutant kind of gave Fox somewhat of a
claim to him and now that Disney owns
Fox that might make name worse
appearance in the MCU a bit more likely
as late as April 2018
Mikey suggested that old contracts would
need to be worked out before they could
move forward with name work but we have
also learned at d23 that Marvel has the
ACE she-hulk Disney Plus Series in the
works
so clearly Marvel is working with
Universal on some of these titles and
Lucy and spider-man back to Sony is
another huge factor affecting how Marvel
could be moving forward in fact it could
be that Feige deliberately waited to
announce Black Panther 2 until he knew
how the spider-man deal was going to
shake out so not only could bring Namor
to the fold allow the MCU to move
forward by bringing home one of the
longtime legacy titles it would also
help open the door to other mutants
joining the MCU and in addition to other
clues connecting Namor to Black Panther
some have looked at one of the final
moments in the black panther film as the
villain kill monger took his final
breaths just burn me in the ocean but my
assess is that jump from ships because
they know death was better than bondage
hoo hoo man powerful final words but
maybe not so final one theory is that
kill mongers sea burial may lead to his
body's retrieval and revival by the
people of Atlantis led by name or
leading to a comeback assault by the Sun
Wakanda and an army of vengeful warriors
from another hidden Kingdom who views
the Black Panther as a traitor and that
conflict could be what led to the
mysterious undersea disturbance that a
coy way was referring to creator of
amazing fan art boss logic offered his
pitch for this black panther Namor cross
over black panther two kings so cool and
even if that's not the title Ryan
Coogler --za bility to introduce a
majestic world hidden in plain sight and
the MCU could set up his black panther
sequel to the same with a newcomer that
Marvel might need now more than ever do
you want Namor to be introduced to Black
Panther 2 comment down below with your
thoughts and theories follow me on
twitter and instagram at a vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
theories about Marvel's future thank you
for joining me and we're talking caster
for Namor
I can't think of a guy better to take
underwater breaths and mr. breathtaking
himself Keanu his name or let's do this
[Music]